le conseil général de la réunion vous
présente lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais
la réunion est une île qui souffre d'une
démographie importante par rapport à sa
géographie
l'activité urbaine est en plein
développement avec une économie en
perpétuelle croissance une liaison
rapide entre les villes est d'une grande
importance car les échanges entre les
communes sont nombreux de fréquents tous
ces paramètres sont que la réunion est
surchargé en véhicules et les
complications sur les trafics routier
augmente chaque année
en plus de la création de grands axes
comme la route des tamarins la réunion
doit adopter d'autres solutions qui peut
proposer des alternatives à ces
difficultés on en parle maintenant d'un
lien social alors que vient de s'achever
la semaine européenne de la mobilité
pour se déplacer d'un endroit à un autre
dans villes la plupart des réunionnais
utilisent leur propre véhicule il y a
bien sûr d'autres moyens de déplacement
tels que les bus
plusieurs réseaux existent ce interne
aux communes sont gérés par les
intercommunalités sinon civis s'ils
restent ca sud était scellé le réseau
car jaune le plus ancien de tous relis
lui les villes entre elles plus de 6
millions de passagers l'empruntent
chaque année comment pourrait-il
s'améliorer à quoi ressemblerait votre
réseau de transport rêver mon rêve c'est
d'avoir un bus
un bus avec de la clim est bon en ce
moment il ya des bus qu'on est coincée
dedans sur un peu grosse et on peut
passer parce qu'il ya des sacs aussi
emporté bernard des bébés pourraient en
protégeant la mère veut pas rentrer on
est coincé et en fait je trouve qu'au
niveau des transports s'est pas passé
pour les jeunes parce que j'habite au co
et donc son jupon jusqu'à la garde va
payer un ticket et c'est plus valide
après paul et quand le car jaune pour
payer un ticket et avait la garde saint
denis on doit encore payer un autre et
peut reprendre le site aller jusqu'à le
ft et bien pas beaucoup de jeunes qui
ont déjà là que la carte de la procédure
à sion tout le temps mais prend le bus
et d'un show en effet trois quatre cinq
et même très bien mettre en place a
tiqué pas par journée ou bien je pas
moins trouver une solution pour que
l'épave est pathétique et parce que
l'ailé dure la vie et les durées avec
l'euro et shawa après faudrait peut-être
aussi améliorer
le confort dans le bus
faudrait peut-être de mettre j'ai pas de
vent de citer les avec de la musique et
pas forcément des trucs comme dans les
avions mais avoir quelque chose de plus
personnel parce que déjà on dit d'eux
m'a dit 'ce n'est cassé dans les buts
mais c'est pas forcément respectée ya
pas il ya personne pour contre des side
donc voilà ça serait bien d'avoir ce
genre de choses il ya un peu plus de
niveau sécurité aussi parce que ya pas
forcément des personnes qui respectent
ou dans les bus et
tenant compte des attentes des usagers
le conseil général souhaite améliorer le
réseau car jaune et en faire dans un
avenir proche un moyen de locomotion
durable peu coûteux et pratique
l'objectif du département et d'apporter
des solutions permettant de désengorger
au maximum lé réseau routier réunionnais
et de ce fait participer au respect de
l'environnement qui est une priorité
pour notre territoire le département une
responsabilité majeure en matière de
transport réunir l'ensemble des usagers
entre réunir et relier l'ensemble des
villes d'un bout à l'autre du
département c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous avons estimé qu'il fallait
qu'il y à tarif unique 2 euros pour
voyager de n'importe quel point du
territoire à n'importe quel autre point
postiers du cameroun à condition que les
agglomérations cinor cirest civis tc au
quart sud
ce soit d'accord pour que les gens
puissent circuler avec le même ticket le
même abonnement papier enfin le réseau
rêver comme peut en parler dont beaucoup
d'usagers sur l'île réunion et la sphère
que le transport collectif soit une
véritable alternative à la voiture c'est
l'objectif que nous poursuivons au
département réunir l'ensemble des
le conseil général et la seule autorité
organisatrice de transport routier
interurbain acteur central avec le
réseau car jaune et 6 million et demi de
voyageurs par an sur le territoire le
département continue d'améliorer ce
service en 2014 et prévoit des lignes
express et semi express effectué en plus
rapidement des liaisons entre les
territoires des lignes est clair avec
une haute qualité de service un réseau
interconnecté aux réseaux locaux un
réseau réellement accessible aux
personnes à mobilité réduite
la mise en service d'un ticket à deux
euros quelle que soit la distance
parcourue vous avez des suggestions ou
des commentaires rejoignez nous sur les
réseaux sociaux ou sur la page de la
communauté des acteurs de déplacement
durable
le conseil général de la réunion vous a
présenté lien social le conseil général
aux côtés des réunionnais